happy smiling and full of life these are  the last images of christina Grimmie  as she performed her final concert  Friday night in Orlando Florida in these  exclusive photos obtained by et the 22  year old voice Alam appears to be in  good spirits and seems completely  comfortable on stage christina wearing a  black crop top matching miniskirt and  boots perform songs from her self-titled  EP as she opened up for the pop rock  band before you exit Orlando Police say  christina was shot by 27 year old Kevin  James Lobel during a post concert  meet-and-greet the suspect killed  himself while Christina died shortly  after she was rushed to the hospital  fans and mini celebs were devastated by  the news of Christina's passing Adam  Levine her coach on the voice tells et  in a statement christina was a natural a  gifted talent that comes along so rarely  she was taken from us too soon I am left  stunned and confused how these things  can conceivably continue to happen in  our world